kyle shanahan
appeared with tim kawakami of the
athletic on his podcast here's a little
from kyle talking about quarterback
philosophy and we'll react to it on the
other side
i i do laugh at the that everyone thinks
that they know exactly what i want on
quarterback because i thought we had a
chance to get the number one free agent
quarterback who was going to be on the
market in our second year um and since
we did people just assume that's how i
would draw it up um which if you draw it
up you're i mean obviously you're going
to give the guy everything um you know i
do believe that you have to be able to
win from the pocket of the sig as a
quarterback or it'll catch up from you
but holy cow if you can run it makes
playing from the pocket a lot easier
because those defenses are going to
change and stuff
kyle shannon has been coaching nfl long
enough for those of us who pay attention
to it to know what he wanted in a
quarterback before trey lance what he
wanted was a guy who would run his
offense like a robot and operate from
the pocket not improvise not not
start you know doing anything other than
what kyle wanted him to do we've known
that right so it is a break it is a
change that's why you thought he was
going for mac jones that's why others
thought it mac jones fits the profile
right that had developed over 20 years
of what kyle shan is looking for
in a quarterback
so yes that's it's not and that's why i
think it's it's odd for him to say i
laugh when people think they know what i
want a quarterback we do know what you
want in a quarterback and it's typically
not a guy who's gonna run and take off
when he's still waiting for the play
that was called to develop chris yeah
that's right i mean hey it's jimmy
garoppolo it's it's kirk cousins it's
matt schaab it's matt ryan it's that
type of guy that was in his history but
obviously you know my assessment of my
friend and what he wanted at quarterback
and the things he like has changed you
know and you see here like here's some
quarterback stats for you running the
football yeah there's been zero threat
of that the last two years as far as at
the position of quarterback anybody
stressing the defense with their legs at
all they're pocket quarterbacks you know
jimmy garoppolo especially he is
less than the modern day athlete at the
quarterback position he is he's less
than average as far as that's concerned
but
i think with a guy like shanahan who's
always looking for new ways to be
cutting edge on the offensive side of
the ball you know whether it's
again i think you know hey mahomes and
seeing what he can do ad-libbing plays
outside the pocket doing that type of
stuff you know we talked about the josh
allen and some of the quotes that came
out of san francisco after they played
him this past year
i think maybe that was
the start of this cycle of maybe a
different shanahan thought process on
the offensive side of the ball and you
know i've heard him say a few quotes
already since he's drafted him just you
know the running quarterback what it
could do for his offense it's a lot like
what i think we're going to see with
sean payton i think they're looking at
it right now going wait i'm really smart
and i've always been able to dice people
up with the normal running game in the
normal passing game but what if i got a
guy that does both how are people what
am i going to be able to do what am i
going to stumble upon that's also going
to be other advantages of unintended
consequences and i think that's where
shanahan is excited right now is that he
could add an element to his offense that
the league maybe is not quite used to
right now
it's impossible to ignore what we've
seen with the quarterbacks who can do
the off-schedule thing who can
turn a bad play into a good play yeah by
improvising the two plays the play
that's called and the play the
quarterback comes up with when the play
that's called goes to hell kirk cousins
is the prime example of a guy who can't
do anything sorry it's true yeah it's
true
when the play that's called goes to hell
he can run the play that's called as
long as it doesn't go to hell right goes
to hell it's done may as well just throw
it straight into the ground at that
point
but when you see what patrick mahomes
can do the guy that
kyle shanahan didn't even bother to
evaluate because he thought he was
getting kirk cousins a year later in
free agency i mean i think that's one of
the reasons why
if he did go into this process
wanting mac jones and was talked out of
it by someone in the organization
patrick mahomes game film would be the
thing that would tend to do it
especially patrick mahomes game films
from super bowl 54.
garoppolo that that's yeah you want you
want another garoppolo
we should be looking at a guy who can be
another mahomes and that's the
difference between jones and lance
potentially yeah no no i mean you're
exactly right there's that potential
there now what's different and what to
me is going to be really interesting and
a lot of pressure here
on the 49ers with the treylands thing
and everything you're talking about and
i'm talking about
is
again
whether how much you liked mahomes or
josh allen or some of these quarterbacks
that came out in the draft and things
like that
we didn't really question their throwing
at all
right and i know people questioned josh
allen's accuracy and things like that
and you've heard my defense of all that
playing up there and why not receivers
stunk everything the offensive line was
as bad as any of i've seen of these top
quarterbacks in the last five years
everything was bad so nothing was going
to be easy for him but the point is you
know at least for me and i think a lot
of people evaluating quarterbacks and
football with some of these quarterbacks
were talking about extending plays there
was never questions about their ability
or inability to throw the football and
do some of those things trey lance there
is you know like we've talked about we
haven't seen two minute warren a
two-minute drill in his college career
we haven't seen him have to play in a
game where you go
your right arm is going to have to win
it today not our north dakota run great
running scheme and you're running and
doing those things you're gonna have to
drop back 45 times and dice somebody up
he's never had to do that and see those
are things that like i didn't question
about those other guys we're talking
about and so that's the the last piece
of the puzzle here is yes i think the
running can be really good i'm not going
to say it's lamar jackson good or
anything like that but
yeah the passing there's there's
questions there there definitely is and
that that to me is gonna be the million
dollar question yeah the running is good
but will he be able to take advantage of
everything within the pocket like
shanahan's talking about to really like
take his game to the next level
i just think all this confusion and
uncertainty traces back to the message
that is necessarily sent when in late
march a team trades from 12 to three
giving up two extra first round picks
and a third round pick to do it and not
knowing what they're doing it for
supposedly we're going up to three we
know we're gonna have the board in our
control after trevor lawrence goes to
jacksonville and zach wilson goes to the
jets and worst case scenario is they
don't and we get one of those guys and
we'll take one of those guys we'll be
thrilled to get one of those guys it's
what the jets did when they moved to
number three in 2018. they were content
to take the third quarterback on their
left that's right
jets knew who their third quarterback
was they knew one two three which way
they'd go
the 49ers didn't okay lawrence wilson
and we'll figure out who number three is
that to me
uh look yeah it's weird
they could have stayed they could have
stayed at 12 and maybe gotten trey lance
or mac jones one of them would have been
there one of them would have been there
you're there's there's there's no doubt
i mean maybe somebody trades up right if
they were at seven or eight we've talked
about washington and things like that
maybe you know but but then again you
know if you're the 49ers and you are
sitting there at 12 you can adjust on
the fly and do that listen i mean yeah
you you talk to anybody
in the nfl who knows anyone
i i it sounds like the representation
for trey lance had no idea where he was
gonna get drafted if the 49ers didn't
take him at three there was like concern
of like wait we don't know we don't have
a team that we really know is in it for
him or wants to draft him or do any of
that so yeah with those things you
connect dots and you go yeah he most
likely could have been there at 12 or he
might have been there at seven or eight
and you wouldn't had to trade three
first round picks to go up and get him
there at that point either so yes that's
something they're gonna have to live
with and that's gonna be part of this
package and story of this whole train
lands draft pick
i i'm thinking back to some of the
quotes from the aftermath of the trade
and i got the sense that there was a
high degree of relief
in the organization that they knew where
they were going to be
and they could quit worrying about that
and i can't help but wonder now did they
make the trade when they did just
because they they didn't think they'd be
able to hold it together for another
month
while they waited for the draft and
waited to see
do we have to trade to three four five
six seven eight nine where do we go what
do we have to do i you know you're
paying a premium yeah just to be in
position where you have the luxury of
evaluating justin field's lane that's
right and mac jones that's a lot to give
up and i just don't i just i just
i don't know whether they didn't think
this through
or whether they just got freaked out by
passing on patrick mahomes passing on
tom brady when he wanted to come play
for the 49ers last year
and they just wanted to be done with
this i i i that the whole thing is odd
to me and then you throw in
the possibility that jimmy garoppolo
isn't going to be traded or cut that he
is going to be the week one starter if
he does stay healthy and play well all
year then you got an even bigger mess it
just feels like this is a mess
that's got the chance to become a huge
mess for the 49ers and it's as unique
as what's going on with aaron rodgers in
the package it is in that you're right i
don't think we've ever seen anything
like this before no you're right it's
it's it's uh it is different i can't
certainly i can't think of like a
scenario like this you know
this many draft picks to trade up to get
you know a guy at three not really
proven yet raw you know but we gave up
all these picks to get a guy that's kind
of raw and unproven and we got a
quarterback here
who's quarterbacked this team that's in
a super bowl window and he's actually
taken the super bowl and had a chance to
win the football game you're right i
mean this is has the makings of being a
soap opera that's for sure it does and i
don't i don't know where it goes and
then you throt into the fact of like
we're talking about a quarterback who
you traded three first round picks to
get to number three
and he didn't play football last year he
played one game and i can just tell you
from my standpoint that one game again
and i don't i'm you know me i don't over
judge that one game would have been
scary enough for me not to take him at
number three i can say that
and feel very confident about it that's
no disrespect i hope trey lance proves
me wrong you know that i'm rooting for
the 49ers i'm room for kyle shanahan
that's that's we know that but yeah that
would have scared the death out of me
and now we're talking about what he's
going to sit on the bench maybe behind
jimmy garoppolo for another year that's
where it's like i i would want to say to
my buddy like hey man if he's close just
go with him play him you'll figure out
how to run the ball with him and take
care of them and i saw you do it with
rg3 and all of that and that washington
team wasn't as good as that 49ers team
he got right now so if trey lance can
handle the offense and could play a
little bit i'd go go go time let's see
what he's got and get him out there get
him playing football you can't let him
sit on the bench for another year at
least in my opinion
i i keep going back
to the common denominator
for the dysfunction in green bay the
dysfunction in san francisco the
dysfunction with the rams where they
dumped jared goff from matthew stafford
the dysfunction with the seahawks
it all traces back to tom brady it's all
brady and mahomes-ish it's already in my
home dish like to your point
and you mentioned the super bowl that
jimmy garoppolo started for the 49ers
that they were winning and then they
fell behind and then emanuel sanders was
open and jimmy garoppolo missed him
this quote from tom brady from the super
bowl pregame show on westwood one with
jim gray of garoppolo
he's got a great opportunity to go out
there today and prove it
that's when you really get to see
whether someone's capable or not
that was tom brady before super bowl 54.
yeah and what did he prove
every step of the way in the 2020 season
as the 49ers saw it
and realized
oh crap we could have had that guy this
year yeah i i really i really do think
that brady's success in his first year
with the buccaneers has broken the
brains
of multiple nfl front offices and also
empowered quarterbacks in a way that's
creating these situations we can look at
and say it's unprecedented green bay
yeah unprecedented 49ers unprecedented
rams unprecedented all because of brady
i i definitely a huge part of it no
doubt i think mahomes is involved in
there too because like of the way he's
playing and how good he is he's affected
the 49ers i think rogers looks at him
and he's like wait brady's got these
guys and i got this young guy who's
tearing the league on fire i was the
freak who threw lasers everywhere and
he's got talent around him so that puts
more pressure on him too or you know
puts more pressure on the situation but
yeah i agree i think you're right i mean
i think you can look at the 49ers the
russell wilson situation and green bay
and go
there's certainly a brady effect a
mahomes effect that has
ruffled the feathers of the quarterback
the organization or whatever or both and
uh yeah i think it's kind of i think it
is real i'm with you there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports